[music]
today the
council recommendations
on vaccinations submitted by the european commission were formally approved
by the council as you know vaccinations
are among the most important and effective
preventive measures available in
medicine and vaccinations are
generally an effective tool in
the fight against communicable
diseases  the mass outbreak in 2017 was
around 14,000 people across europe and in the
period from october 2017 to 2 september
218, 37 people died of measles
deaths that could really
have been avoided through vaccinations in the exchange of
ideas about the
challenge and opportunities to lead
how a digitized world can also
support
in the  to circumvent vaccination
skepticism or to find measures
to work more effectively here
left-wing faction leader grow grow
grow
[music]